如果我们单谈先进制程
美国跟中国大陆的差距
我认为至少在三到五年
我要说一句实在话
要是美国把所有的
那中国大陆会追得很快
那这样子全世界的晶圆场
包含台积电都要有你的压力
大家好
欢迎收看富足今周期
我是主持人王志玉
AI的趋势啊
一路的往前冲
很多人一定都赚到了资本利得
但接下来是不是要开始分歧了
有些真的有基本面
有些可能只是炒题材
我们要如何分辨
今天我们就请到了专家
请到了知识力执行长
曲建仲曲伯你好
主持人好
各位观众朋友大家
好我们先来看
我们在网路上做了一个调查
就问问大家
这个AI科技股涨到这个地方
你会怎么看这个趋势啊
讲太多了
担心一次奉還嗎
會怕的有48%
不怕的52%
所以其實應該是一半一半啦
所以呢面對這個問題
我就要請教一下這個曲波
你怎麼看哦
到底你會是哪一邊
會怕還是覺得還好
基本上呢我認為
應該要怕
要怕了是不是
因為呢
激高思維
這個是投資市場永遠不變的真理
我們回顧過去每一年
股市呢只要發生反轉
幾乎都是在最高點
大家最興奮的時候
也就是擦鞋同理論
當你看到路邊擦鞋的人
都已經在跟你說要買台積電
你就要開始警惕
但是會不會擔憂一次奉還
我認為不會
這個原因很複雜
主要很多因素
因為世界各國印了太多鈔票
這也是原因之一
金融市場發行了非常多的ETF
也造成了整個資金的行情
所以我個人認為
不會有一次奉還這種狀況
但是呢還是需要怕
要怕但是不用不用那麼怕
應該是這樣講
好這是曲博這個提醒大家
好那接下來我們就要進入到這個
一個一個的這個
可以說最近很熱的題材
然後我們請曲博趕快用他的專業眼光給我們看
因為你知道我們看一般的媒體
你就會覺得好像都是很熱鬧很熱鬧
你看不太到那當中最重要的點在哪
所以呢我們先要請曲博
我們一起先來看看
這個是一個這個外國的媒體
那他就提到了
他说这个接下来一直到年底
他认为呢有五家公司
他的股价呢可能会再涨三成
然后他就点兵点将点了这五家
所以这五家呢到底他们基本面怎么样
就请曲博帮我们看看了
他的这个前提是说
AI基础建设呢会一路一路的继续扩大当中
所以这五家受惠
第一家当然台积电
再来回答博通、微软跟Meta
那我们就一家一家请这个曲博帮我们看看
台积电应该是毫无疑问
那曲波怎么看台积电目前的
这一波的需求
其实就是靠人工智慧
独撑大梁
由它扛起来的
那我们之前也谈过很多次就是
开餐厅的不一定会赚钱
但是呢
卖锅子的一定会赚
因为世界各国的这个云端服务供应商
现在都还是拼命的投入资本
建立所谓的人工智慧的资料中心
或者是辉达讲的人工智慧工厂
那这个趋势目前还没有变慢
所以呢
做锅子的一定赚
所以呢台积电一定赚
是
所以呢坦白说台积电未来
这两年的业绩会非常好
这件事是板上定定
非常肯定
很肯定
所以你刚刚就说嘛
要不要紧张呢
坦白说我们要谨慎
但是不用那么紧张
我们也要居高思维
但是我们还是要去了解
目前市场实际的需求的状况
所以我想
第一个是台积电
因为他的竞争对手
坦白说还没有办法追上他
那在供给有限的状况下
当然台积电独挑大量
业绩一定很大
好那再来辉达
那辉达呢也是硬体供应商
所以基本上他的业绩也不会差
所以曲伯的定义当中
他也是卖锅子的那个
当然当然辉达一定是
他是卖锅子
他也有一些软体
不过他的主要营收都是卖锅子
所以这个伺服器相关的产品
而且越做产品界越完整
是
所以我想这个业绩好也不是问题
但是我还是要提醒大家
其实业绩好跟股市这个股价好
这是两件事
我一直要强调
因为我的专业不是在股票
我的专业是产业
所以我想产业这个未来两年
这两个公司会非常好
没有问题
那博通也做这个通讯相关的这个晶片
所以他也是硬体供应商
所以也不会有问题
而且大家知道博通其实是设计公司
所以他的晶片都是台积电代工
又回到台机店头上
那讲微软跟Meta
就要再讨论了
为什么呢
微软跟Meta是软体公司
所以它主要是靠软体营收
那其中这个微软
我个人认为它的业绩
也不至于差
是因为它主要还是靠过去
作业系统
还有这个我们用的Office
这些相关软体
那另外它也有提供这个云端服务
我想这个部分呢
因为它有基本的业绩
像这种公司不用担心
是
Meta也是
它是脸书
那它只靠网络广告
对
那基本这两种公司呢
都有基本营收
所以我想
只是说营收
有没有成长如大家预期
嗯哼
但是基本
这个公司都不会有问题
是没问题
那反而大家要稍微担心的是那种
到现在还在烧钱的公司
哦
譬如像OpenAI
它虽然这个风头很盛嘛
好像它是
第一个
做出这个深层次人工智慧
聊天机器人成功的公司
但是你要回頭去看
他到現在還在燒錢
而且燒非常多那這種沒有基礎的營收來支撐他進行这种人工智慧军备竞赛的状况下那大家就要稍微担心了
这个就要谨慎的看待它
但是我个人认为这间公司也不会有问题
因为它最坏最坏最坏的状况
大概就是被并购
所以其实我个人认为也不用太过紧张
OK好那这个是目前我们看到的
这个是被外国媒体点兵的这个五家公司
但是很好奇的是
这当中没有Google
但Google不是明明
它的Gemini不是最近大家说
那个很令人眼睛为之一亮
但为什么没有Google
我们看了嘛
这个国外媒体
它最后一个字叫富偶
所以它漏掉了
它漏掉了是不是
我个人认为Google绝对应该榜上有名
这一波的深层智能工智慧的起源
就是Transformer Model
变换模型
这个是Google发明的
所以千万不要漏掉它
那Google的Jermynon
经过一些调整之后
它的表现也慢慢追上OpenAI
所以呢
虽然一开始落后
但是就慢慢就追上
不要忘了
Google是属于有基础收入的公司
对
所以它跟Meta跟微软比起来
它绝对没有比较差
所以我个人认为
这个应该要榜上有名才对
是
所以应该是有六档股票
这个是六家公司
应该都是基本面是没有问题的
走在趋势上嘛
对吧
那其实呢
最近我们也看到了
相关于AI开始
长出了很多的支线
各式各样
可以用在AI基础建设上的
然后现在正在大缺货的
哇都会变成那个当红渣子机
所以我们就要请曲博
来帮我们看看他们的基本面
我们先来看记忆体
好那记忆体呢
其实现在已经变成大家的共识
觉得他的需求就是不够
那就是供不应求
所以我们来看到
有这个研调机构说
他会一直缺货
缺到2027年下半年
这个是我们比较普遍
听到的一个这个年份数字
但最近SK海力士的这个老董
他就讲了
他说哦没有
会缺到2030年
所以呢关于记忆体这个问题
我就想请教曲博
就是以你们这个看产业趋势的来讲
记忆体真的会缺货缺到
这么遥远的未来吗
我想目前业界的资讯呢
记忆体缺货到
2027年下半年应该是蛮明确的
一般的认为是
这样子没有问题
那至于会不会缺到2030年这件事
我觉得还要再观察
但是我觉得这件事还是要回到源头
到底这一波的需求都是人工智慧出来的
那这些人工智慧是真的很有用吗
这个要去讨论嘛
那目前到底遇到什么困难
我觉得现在没有办法确认的原因
就是因为我们之前谈过
人工智慧的模型
会有一本正经胡说八道的问题
这个问题到目前会是没有解决的
他还是在胡说八道
還是在無所謂
所以最近那個中國大陸流行
所謂養龍蝦對不對
結果呢養沒有幾個月
我朋友一直問我
要不要養一隻
我說我不急著養
原因很簡單
因為我那個時候就說
我認為他們的熱潮大概就三個月
三個月之後一定有很多人嚇到
開始要泄龍蝦
泄宰為什麼
你想想看你敢在你的電腦裡面
安裝一個人工智慧代理
幫你處理很多事情
不需要你拍板
他就幫你執行
而這一個人工智慧代理會亂來
會一本正經胡說八道嗎
他本來只是一本正經胡說八道就在嘴上
他現在會幫你一本正經亂做事
對這個很危險啊
災情到處都是
你敢用這樣的人工智慧代理幫你買股票嗎
我不敢幫你管理硬碟嗎
哪一天資料突然不見了
所以我覺得問題還是出在
當然也可能會賺錢啦
有時候股票亂買也會賺
重點還是在於這種技術門檻必須克服
對
人工智慧的很多应用才可以落实
对
这些应用落实之后
那人工智慧的需求
我觉得就可以达到
刚刚这一个会长说的到2030年
所以曲博士觉得现在的状况还没有到
可以让大家放心的使用它
是
所以你就回想
我讲人工智慧的应用
大家觉得很抽象
然后大家就聊天机器人
其实也不止
你只要回想
钢铁人电影里面的Javis就可以了
有没有那个Tony男主角
每次遇到问题
就会去问Javis
对不对
Javis就帮他查资料啊
帮他做很多事
帮他整理资料
然后告诉他一个答案
但问题来了
如果Javis在电影里面
随便胡说八道
你觉得这种人工智慧能用吗
钢铁人早就在一件
你可能又好奇
那为什么厂商到现在还在投资
还拼命的砸钱呢
原因就是因为还没有落实
所以他们要想办法让它落实
那在这个初期呢
一定是要投资更多的成本
做更多的模型训练啊
模型的改良啊
然后等到这个技术能够慢慢升级
就希望未来有一天
他就跟电影里面的Javis一样
但很抱歉的是
这件事情还没有发生
所以目前人工智慧可以做到的
我觉得还是一些参考
比如说你要搜寻一个资料
你懒得自己找
你就问他
让他帮你整理
可是很多时候整理完
我看半天我也不确定到底真的还假的
对我还得回头去查一遍
我还得回头再去double check
所以在这种状况下
你就会对这个人工智慧
是有是无
好像有也好
好像没有也不是那么严重
对
所以它还是必须技术发展到
突破这个瓶颈之后
那么再来判断这个会比较准准
OK好
这个是记忆体的一个部分
它的确是会缺到2027
但是它能不能继续的往下走
那就要看看它实用上面
大家用的状况如何
而且这个判断不是只有记忆体
包括我们刚刚讲的那些公司
都是
都是一样
因为如果整个技术不能突破
对
那整个需求可能就会不如预期
OK
所以我想未来这两年的观察是非常重要
但另外有一个新讲出来的商机
我就要请教许伯了我们来看就是即将成为这个史上最大的IPO案SpaceX然后你看到那个马斯克他有一个梦以后伺服器我们就到太空去
所以大家最近都在谈那个
低轨卫星太空商机
好那这个到底会不会变成
下一个很重要的
推动AI走的一个商机呢
这个SpaceX的价值是在于说
它让人类要上外太空
这样的事情变得更容易
可行性更高
是
那目前全世界做這種火箭回收技術
也只有他們這個公司做得最好
目前雖然很多廠商都努力要做
但是那個落差我認為至少都是5年以上
你要追上他很難
那我想這個IPO應該今年會很成功
剛好又遇到這個資本市場很熱的時候
他最重要的關鍵還是去回到衛星
那因為火箭回收技術讓發射火箭成本降低
才可以發射幾萬顆的衛星來提供
地面网路不足的时候的补充
这边有一个关键就是
不要以为说这个卫星会取代我们的手机
这是不会的
卫星通讯归卫星通讯
地面的基地台还是地面的基地台
因为成本还是不一样
但是在一些欧美或者是澳洲
加拿大他们那种地广人稀的地方
或者东南亚
像印尼听说有好几万个岛屿
那种地方你要拉光线
难度很高
那这个卫星就是非常好的解决方案
所以我想这个公司会成功这件事
应该是没有任何问题
那下一步就是马斯克说过
要发射100万颗卫星
把这个地面的
人工智慧的资料中心
办到外太空
那我想这一种说法
目前只能够当作是一个参考
参考啊
因为难度非常的高
非常多的技术没有办法克服
可能是马斯克为了要挂牌的一种
这一个炒作手法
让公司更有热度
这个部分大家要打个问号
我没有说一定做不到
因为在技术上确实一直在进步
或许现在是不可能
那 maybe 10年 20年以后
或许有可能
但是呢
它的低轨道卫星是很成功的
我想这个是无庸置疑
那低轨道卫星
目前我们看到台湾
其实最近也一直在吵这个话题
说台湾有很多的供应链
那都是这个SpaceX
未来的很可能的一些合作伙伴
那到底我们台湾的一些供应链
台湾的厂商在低轨卫星当中
是不是目前在世界当中
我们的技术真的一流
是的
但是我们都是做零组件
所以你看到这边所有的公司
几乎都是提供零组件
对
坦白说台湾没有所谓卫星产业
我们的产业就是提供人家零组件
所以我们不太有自己的卫星
其实是有
但是那种实验性质的
你要做到像SpaceX这样的规模
那是不可能的事
确实我们也很难做到
但是能够提供这些相关的零组件
我认为这个在产业链
也是扮演重要的角色
但是呢大家一定要再看到
更深一层的问题
就是当地球表面呢
包覆了几万颗地毁到卫星的时候
想想也是蛮可怕的
那有一大堆的太空垃圾
对
所以接下来呢大家开始就要思考
是不是要出现一种专门回收
太空垃圾的公司
真的有这样的公司
真的
所以簡單的說就是人類的產業
已經慢慢從這個地球表面
延伸到外太空去
那這個外太空各位看
想到的可能只是衛星
但是我們還要再看更遠
我們要想到未來可能譬如說
太空垃圾的回收啦
甚至我最近發現美國的新創公司呢
還有做太空 隕石 礦石的開採這樣的公司
可以開採啊
非常有趣喔
那可不可行不知道
但是各位知道美國
他们就有那样的环境去培养这种
算是很有创意 很特别
我们也没办法说它很难成功
不知道
总是技术要持续的前进
但是我只是强调就是
可能大家要花一点点时间来研究一下
这种太空经济
未来有哪些新的发展
对 所以太空经济其实是包罗万象的
只是我们现在还没有看到而已
现在我们就只想到那个低伪卫星上太空
但上了太空之后以后就会
很多垃圾也要解决
太空当中有很多其他的东西
都是商机
这个我们都可以好好来关注他一下
好那继续呢
我们就要请教这个曲播的是
我们来看看这个近来
你看到了这个
黄仁星不断在讲一句话
就是他一直告诉大家说
不要小看中国
然后他甚至呢
讲了这句话
他是这样讲
他的原话说
中国大陆在晶片制造领域
只落后美国籍奈渺
奈渺呢
还要告诉你什么叫奈渺
叫做十亿分之一秒
有这么快吗
这好像跟我们的理解不太一样
那当然我们会赋予他很多的一些解读
说哎呀他就是想要到中国做生意啦
所以他就一直这样讲
但是呢这个问题其实很值得讨论吧
到底中国现在的晶片发展到什么地步啊
是像黄仁勋讲的这么少这么少吗
还是其实有一段距离是永远追不到呢
取不过你的看法呢
基本上这个绝对不要小看中国大陆
这个是一定的
一定的
是一定的
千萬不要小看
大家如果去我的YouTube的頻道上看
就會發現很多網友就跟我嗆聲
但是我必須老實說
只要是業內的專家
所謂業內就是真的在跟
全世界做生意
包含跟中國大陸的廠商
合作甚至競爭的
業界朋友
從來沒有一個跟我說
可以小看大陸的廠商
真的
所以他們的競爭力是很可怕的
14億人
你說是不是
只若後美國幾耐秒呢
我認為這個是誇大的
誇大了
對
你剛剛說出來了
就是黃仁勳執行長
想要把產品賣到中國去
是
所以他當然就一直想要
給美國一些壓力告訴你們很機 很機你要趕快賣但是我要強調一件事就是如果我們單談先進製程美國跟中國大陸的差距
我認為至少在3到5年
所以其實不算小
會有這種差距的原因
主要還是因為
美國封鎖了極紫外光設備
賣進大陸
這個確實是把那個時間
拉得比較長
我要說一句實在話
实在的话
要是美国把所有的封锁
统统取消
那中国大陆会追得很快
就真的是差这几耐秒
不见得只差几耐秒
但是呢
可能那个落差就只有一两年了
那这样子全世界的金元场
包含台积电都要有压力
所以坦白说啦
美国做了这个封锁之后
确实让大陆在进步的过程中
会更辛苦
但是你也要倒过来看
那就意味着哪一天
中国大陆要是克服了
极止外光技术的问题的话
那他会追得很怕
很可怕
为什么因为他完全没有任何人
可以拦得住他了
这么可怕
蒙古粗杂的概念是不是
事实就是这样子
所以我常讲就是
我的想法跟黄金執行长有一点
包含所有业界专家
都是同样的想法
你去封锁中国大陆呢
当然你会让他的发展速度变慢
相反的你也是在协助他
扶植本土供应链
对
所以就延续到下一个问题
这个中国大陆的半导体设备
國產化飆到55%
他的速度很快
至於你想想
今天假設
所有的餐廳都不賣便當給你
你會餓死嗎
不會啊
一定不會嘛
你會怎麼做
自己煮啊
自己買菜啊
一開始煮的很難吃啊
煮幾次之後
就越煮越厲害啊
熟練了嘛對不對
同樣的道理啊
你今天不賣設備給中國大陸
難道人家就不會自己做嗎
會嘛
一開始可能做的很不好對不對
對
可是慢慢改慢慢改就會越來越好
我想道理是完全一樣
是完全一樣
是 那我好奇
那如果曲博認為他追得很快
那你認為他的極紫外光的設備
這個是他有辦法克服的嗎
沒有沒辦法克服的技術
真的嗎
這個華為的創辦人
任正非董事長講過一句話
我覺得講得非常棒
他說今天是人造的
不是神造的
只要做過工程的人就知道
其實任何的技術
都是要靠時間
Try and Error
嘗試跟錯誤做出來
只是時間長跟短而已
今天如果可以直接买到这个东西拿来用
对
那我就可以省掉这个
尝试跟错误的时间
是
那你今天如果
不给我这个设备
那我就只好自己去做尝试跟错误
嗯哼
所以迟早这个会
克服
会做出来
最后呢我就想请这个曲伯
可不可以给我们一点这个
很多人大家现在还陷入那个AI的一个
这个感觉很像
Party当中很开心对不对
那其实曲伯一开始就告诉大家了
你不用太担心
但你要戒胜恐惧
对对对
是吧
那你這個曲播來看的話
你認為就是我們在投資上
因為很多人已經開始講
就是那個過去隨便亂講到AI
我就他說他有AI我就買就會賺錢
這樣的日子是不是已經過去了
接下來我們的選股策略上投資上
看這個產業趨勢是不是應該要更聚焦在
你認為哪一些會比較確定
對這個非常重要
因為人工智慧的發展
確實過去這一段時間
幾乎大家通通都賺錢
但是未來還是這樣嗎
我覺得就要開始區分
像我们刚刚讲
做软体的公司
如果他原来就有基底营收的
这种公司可能就相对是稳的
如果到现在还在那边拼命烧钱的
那相对就是风险比较高的
那同样的道理我再举一个例子
像矽光子
最近只要是矽光子相关的股票啊
哇那个炒翻天对不对
那本益比甚至都到100倍了
但是这个就是一个好例子
矽光子到了下一代之后
会进入所谓的共同封装光学
那是不是所有的这些细光子的公司
它的营收都会因此在爆发性成长呢
答案是不对
不是哦
不是这样
原因是什么呢
因为当共同封装光学的技术
慢慢成长成熟之后
传统的这些所谓的光收发模组
它的业绩其实是会减少的
换句话说因为被取代
那问题又来了
那为什么现在这一些公司业绩都这么好
就是因为共同封装光学还没做出来
还不成熟嘛
所以问题又来了
那现在这么多细光子的概念鼓励
哪些是有搭上共同封装光学
也就是下一个世代的细光子技术
哪一些没有搭上
还在做传统的光收发模组
你就必须要花时间去区分开来嘛
因为有跟上的
下一波才会持续成长
那没跟上的掉队的
他下一波是往下
所以我想这个就是为什么
我一直强调要做投资人
坦白说还是得花一点时间来学科技
你必须知道你买的股票到底在做什么
而不是盲目的
这个听说哪一支公司多棒多棒
你就闭着眼睛买
这种时代已经过去了
接下来就是要更认真的做功课
然后才能够判断出实际产业发展的方向
这样才不会出错
真的我们台湾是科技岛
你要投资科技产业
然后你一窍不通
人家跟你说CPU
你都不知道CPU是什么
你还以为是什么
某种什么机器人是不是
然后就去买了
根本就是弄不清楚状况
大家还是要用功一点
对不对
天上能有这个白吃的午餐
我们要认真做功课
你的投资才会一直走在正确的道路上
好那今天非常谢谢曲博来跟我们分享
那同时呢也谢谢大家的收看
不想让大家觉得AI的热潮当中
你自己最看好哪一个族群呢
听完这个曲博
今天跟大家这个知识含金量非常高的分享
你有什么想法
欢迎在影片下方留言跟我们分享啰
今天谢谢你的收看
我们下回见
拜